before i start this video i just want to
thank dadaiku for partnering with me to
make this video possible dadaiku is the
platform for everyday ai what i love
about them is they make managing data
and ai so easy that non-coders can be
autonomous with their data prep
analytics encoders can only step in for
fancier more interesting problems to
solve but more on that at the end
how does a few pins on a map end up
becoming the biggest crime tracking
system in the us
this is a story of how comstat was born
a system that pushed police departments
to become more data-driven which changed
the course of law enforcement in new
york city
to understand the significance of this
we first have to go back 40 years
the bloodiest year in the history of new
york new york preliminary murder rate
that released today is
784 homicides we're starting off the new
year with at least 10 murders in the
1980s new york city was a lawless place
crime had reached epidemic proportions
over 2 000 murders and 600 000 serious
felonies committed every year the city
seemed beyond redemption but there was
one person who saw it differently and if
given the chance he believed he could
fix the city
his name was jack mabel
[Music]
[Music]
jack maple plotted every single crime
onto a map each pin represented a single
crime color coded and marked to
represent the time of day and the
different crimes that allowed him to
find patterns in a way looking at raw
numbers simply could not it also allowed
him to be one step ahead of the
perpetrators jack called them the charts
of the future
but not everyone understood them
picasso's still going at it
man [ __ ] that guy his old transit cop
acting like he runs his place 100 bucks
says
he gets can within three months yeah
more like two
hey i wish i could do arts and crafts
all day too
lieutenant what is this
it's what's gonna save this city bill
come on
[Music]
see these great pins
wolf pack robberies
same time same place every night
this this uh pickpockets in times square
i'll follow the red pinch
move to downtown on west 4th
every afternoon
what are these
purse snatchings
notice anything
same tray line
and at the same time too
see with jack's map crime patterns were
visualized meaning they could be
predicted
those yellow pins on the map
they let the police know where and when
they'd catch next per snatching
turns out it was just one guy's doing
once he was in cuffs poof no more yellow
pins on the map
with jack sharks the future the nypd
realized most of the crimes in their
city were actually done by a small
percentage of people
track them understand them and arrest
them it's time we start fighting crime
not just responding to it
and just like that felony crime at a
subway dropped 30 in two years outside
new york city was still a cesspool but
the subways were safer than ever before
in 1994 new york city got a new police
commissioner bill bratton he'd seen what
jack maple had accomplished with the
charts of the future so he wanted him to
do the same thing but this time for all
of new york city so he made him his
deputy and together they would turn the
charts of the future into what we know
today as com staff want every
to track every single crime that happens
daily every robbery every murder even a
sneeze and i want to know about it
okay nothing slips through the cracks
i need to hold our own people
accountable
they already report them to the
commission
and things have been pretty quiet
what
quiet
we've already had 30 murders this week
last year we had 1946.
look quiet my ass this is the murder
capital of the [ __ ] world
they're ignoring cases all right police
departments just won't tell you about it
you need to force them to take every
single crime seriously from now on
well if they're keeping the bad news
away from the commission aren't they
gonna do the same to you well then we
gotta force it out of them
how are we gonna do that sir
i'll just kindly ask them of course
lots of robberies in the fifth precinct
what's going on commander
a lot more heroin up there sir
really
no kidding
where is it
it's uh where's it coming in who's
dealing we haven't really how do you
know that it's the uh
heroinetics that are doing these
robberies well as i said before we have
an active investigation
oh
what does that mean
now tell me exactly
what that means
now you woke up in the morning you went
to work
what exactly did you do
to catch these guys
if you don't got answers
i sure as hell will find someone who
does
dismissed
last year we recovered 800 000 from the
boa robbery
six months ago the four-year-old son of
a world-renowned pianist was found
thanks to us now we're working on our
biggest homicide case yet that's what we
do we don't have the resources nor the
time for these low-level cases
where do you live commander
i don't see how that's clockstown one of
these places
what'd you pay for your house 300 000
350.
got a nice little police department
there huh
now wouldn't you be on the phone with
the clocks down [ __ ] cops
and wouldn't you want these crackheads
arrested
and if they say oh geez sir don't you
understand they're just low-level guys
now we're working on a big case
and we'll be done with that big case in
about i don't know a year
would that be all right if your children
were stepping on crack biles on their
way to school
so why the [ __ ] would it be all right
for your precinct
i'll get out
police chiefs hated comstat from the
meetings to the date of reporting but
that forced him to take every single
crime seriously because of that the
crime rate in new york city plunged
only a year after bretton took over the
murder rate dropped 25 percent a year
after that 40 percent
comstat worked it revolutionized the
department and became a symbol of police
accountability things were going well
for new york until people who didn't
understand the machine started running
it
when jack stepped down in 1996 people
started using comstat as a management
tool setting impossible numbers to hit
rather than making the city safer it
became a numbers game
year after year the crime rate would go
down but what was really behind those
numbers
apparently due to the immense pressure
to lower the crime rate police chiefs
started fudging numbers downgrading
crimes or even stop reporting them
for some it was the only way not to get
fired
they were so focused on moving the
metric it no longer solved the actual
problem
we have to remember that
behind those numbers and statistics are
real people with their own individual
stories
and no story can be reduced into a
single number
that's why we'll always need the human
element in a data-driven system to keep
it in check
comstat's data-driven approach remains a
controversial one
on the one hand it almost definitely led
to smarter policing and a safer city
on the other hand it became
justification for police abuses perhaps
the answer is that like all machines
they can only be as effective as the
people running it and the data that goes
into it
data is not a solution but a tool to be
used in the hands of responsible leaders
and that's where you come in
thanks for watching this video if you
like this story there are plenty more to
discover on history of data science.com
and you can even try to win the graphic
novel innovators of data science which
tells the stories of the 12 people who
had the most significant impact on the
history of data science on the website
history of data science you'll learn how
data science was used to fight the kova
19 pandemic how it was used back in the
19th century to fight cholera what a.i
winter means why the dartmouth
conference was so important and a lot
more cool stuff and this is all done by
dadeku which is a sponsor of this video
so about dadaiku it's a platform for
everyday ai it makes designing deploying
and managing ai super easy for me since
i was mainly doing analytics at facebook
i think their analytics application
would have been extremely helpful
i'm not a big fan of writing code just
for the sake of writing code because it
just slows you down but with their
platform instead of writing custom
scripts to clean your data create
pipelines and deploy your model it's all
in one easy to use platform this way you
can focus on solving more interesting
machine learning problems
alright that's it i'll see you in the
next one